Please welcome head of data 42 at
Noartis, Burgett Sherbold. [Music]
Good morning. Now we're switching gears. My name
is Burg Shouba, head of data 42 at Novartis.
Novartis is a leading global medicines company
and we focus on science and innovation. I'm really
excited to be here today to share with you how
we re-imag the way we discover novel lifesaving
medicines with the power of data and AIP. So as
many probably know the pharmaceutical company
uh pharmaceutical industry faces a big challenge.
Currently it takes us about 12 years on average
and three billion dollars to develop a novel
medicine. This is largely driven by a low
probability of success with an odds ratio of 1 in
10,000 um for one of our discovery stage molecules
synthesized by chemists early on to ever reach
regulatory approval. So this is not a problem we
can solve with vibe coding alone. So at Novartis
we believe that the probability that improving
the probability of success requires three uh
critical elements. So one is a democratized
access to contextenriched integrated data across
discovery preclinical clinical and real world
data. worldclass scientific talent and on top of
that in intelligent tools including predictive and
generative models that support our scientists
in making breakthrough discoveries going way
beyond the classical productivity tools. So
for our scientists and for me honestly it's
not the goal to go home 30 minutes earlier
to walk my dog. It's really I want to improve
this odds ratio and help our patients who are
waiting um for a new med life-saving treatment.
With Palunteer as our partner, we're building a
framework that allows us to use AI agents with
scientific depth anchored in our data. So let me
share today two examples. So we started working
with Palunteer um relatively early on in 2019
to develop the technology behind data 42. Some
of you might wonder why 42 and I guess I have the
coolest job title probably here in the room. Uh
we are inspired by the hitchhiker's guide to the
galaxy. So in order to find the answer to life,
the universe and everything, data 42's mission is
to leverage and unlock the value of Novartis' data
in a secure and well-governed way. This includes
proprietary compound data, pre-clinical efficacy
and safety data, clinical data including lab data
and biomarket data as well as real world data. For
example, health uh electronic health records. You
can see that some of the data especially biomarket
data can be quite sensitive but also highly
complex. And in order to really fully understand
our clinical data, it is essential that we're able
to link the structured data to unstructured data
in our clinical trial protocols or scientific
reports. So by leveraging the ontology and AIP,
data 42 has been able to combine tens of billions
of rows of data from over 700 um million patient
lives from real world data as well as from our
3,000 clinical trials encompassing about a million
patients. So this data is now instantly available
and all within the secure and well-governed
environment. So we have encoded um our rich domain
knowledge into the ontology by building agents
that can extract and connect data across multiple
um data domains and metadata captured in our
documents. In this way, you can easily explore AIP
generated links that connect a single compound as
you can see here in yellow with our clinical trial
data shown in red, biomarker data in green and
preclinical data. So now let's take a first uh uh
look at the one example of how data explorers can
easily query and visualize real world data from
this massive enriched ontology using one of our
AIP and augmented tools that is now in production
and used across Novartis. It's called Chat RWE.
Let's say you're a clinical scientist supporting a
project team that is planning a new clinical trial
in breast cancer maybe. So the first question
is can I enroll patients? Do I find the patients
given certain inclusion and exclusion criteria? Uh
the answer is quite complex using real world data.
you typically need to ask a data scientist
because you probably don't know how to write
SQL queries and so it takes time and maybe you
just uh move on but now with uh chat RWE that
uh democratizes the access to data with rapid
decision making and allows us to run um these
cohort feasibility assessments really quickly. So
in the chat RW tool, the immense complexity of the
data traversal, the synonym retrieval and output
uh generation is hidden behind a very intuitive
uh user interface. You can see there's a chat and
a set of curated visualizations that empower our
scientists to understand whether a generated
cohort is a good foundation for their research
questions. So these visualizations are designed
to provide the data explorer with the necessary
context on the underlying data such as for
example the distribution of age, the coorbidities,
clinical labs, lines of prior treatments etc for
the uh patient population of interest. Yet for our
data scientists that's really where their work
starts and uh having access to the multimodal
data available on data 42 they can now go uh
do their work in a familiar procode environment
such as Jupyter notebook uh to build for example
new ML or AI models. So now let's take a look at
the second example that is uh in production. We
call it closing the loop. um you will see why.
It's an application that we use in all of our uh
early discovery project teams where we are making
hundreds or thousands of uh compounds to predict
the anticipated human dose. So if you think about
uh taking out risk, it's critical to understand
and predict what might happen in human. And here
we can now uh predict the anticipated human dose
for all of our discovery molecules, learn and
uh compare with our clinical data at scale and
using this automated workflow uh and AI agents as
I will show you in a little bit. Our goal here
was to enable one translational modeler to do
something that actually they were not really able
to do before. And if done for all projects um at
scale basically it would take a much bigger team.
So you can see that closing the loop is yes it's
about gaining efficiencies but it also is will
improve and improves our prediction quality and
leads to novel insights. So predicting the right
dose from animal experiments is a very complex
kinetic modeling process with multiple options. So
what we've done with Palunteer's AIP agents is to
automate the creation of all possible scenarios.
This is what wasn't possible before allowing the
modeler to test um the impact of different input
data and scaling methods. If you do this manually,
it just explodes and takes a lot of time. valuable
pieces of decision rationale and scientific
context are captured back into the ontology
to create a true knowledge base that supports
improved predictions downstream. So capitalizing
on that, we've constructed AIP agents that combine
the insights from historical clinical studies that
have been integrated into the data 42 ontology as
well as organizational and industry best practices
um to provide recommendations uh on modeling
decisions. So with every prediction and every
scientific piece of context that we capture um
as lab nodes, this ontology is enriched and will
inform our future predictions. The AI agent it not
only works through the layers of the workflow
but is also able to transparently justify its
recommendations to the modeler while the ontology
allowing for a true human AI partnership. So at
the end of this workflow, all modeling decisions,
all generated charts charts and all data utilized
um from the ontology are transformed into an
electronic lab notebook entry with traceable
sources and transparent artifacts to guarantee
rep reproducibility. So in summary, I hope you
can see that through this combination of agentic
automated and ad hoc decision making support with
full decision traceability, we've been able to
reduce the time one of our translational modelers
usually spends on the human dose prediction per
compound by approximately 90 98% from one week
down to two hours. Today, almost 100% of our small
molecule projects use closing the loop to help us
increase our consistency, reproducibility, and to
derisk projects much earlier and thus increases
our probability of success. So to summarize, if
you comprehensive data, brilliant scientists,
and truly intelligent tools, you can fundamentally
change the process of drug discovery. So imagine
being able to sub supercharge also your data
scientist with best-in-class access to data,
efficient tools, and increasingly autonomous
and contextrich agents. Thank you. [Applause]